witnesses not come forward in the face
of the president's threats and testified
about the Ukraine shakedown and it's
scandalous effects on our national
security our democracy and our
constitutional system of government but
make no mistake while this investigation
was saved by the courage and
old-fashioned patriotism of witnesses
like ambassador William Taylor
ambassador Maria yovanovich Lieutenant
Colonel Alexander VIN Minh and dr. Fiona
Hill the president's aggressive and
unprecedented resistance to
congressional subpoenas for witnesses
and documents is blatantly and
dangerously unconstitutional if accepted
and normalized now it will undermine
perhaps for all time the Congressional
impeachment power itself which is the
people's last instrument of
constitutional self-defense against a
sitting president who behaves like a
king and tramples the rule of law by
obstructing an impeachment inquiry with
impunity the president will have the
power to actively destroy the people's
final check on his own corrupt
misconduct and abuse of power the
framers insisted that we have
impeachment in the Constitution
precisely to protect ourselves from a
president becoming a tyrant and a despot
and we cannot and we will not allow the
impeachment power itself to be destroyed
hmm these articles charge that president
Trump is engaged in systematic abuse of
his powers obstructed Congress and
realized the worst fears of the framers
by subordinating our national security
and dragging foreign powers into
American politics to corrupt our
elections all for the greater cause of
his own personal gain and ambition
article 1 section 4 of the Constitution
provides that the President shall be
impeached for treason bribery or other
high crimes and misdemeanors this is the
essential check that the people's
representatives maintained over the
executive branch as our constitutional
expert witnesses testified the
sought to capture a broad range of
presidential misconduct and wrongdoing
through this provision but the
commanding and comprehensive impulse for
including the impeachment power in the
Constitution was to prevent the
president's abuse of power which the
framers saw as the very essence of
impeachable conduct in Federalist number
65 Hamilton wrote that impeachable
offenses are defined by abuse of some
public trust from the Federalist Papers
and the records of the Constitutional
Convention and the ratifying conventions
we find that the framers feared
principally three kinds of betrayal of
office by abuse of power abuse of power
by exploiting public office for private
political or financial gain number one
number two abuse of power by betraying
the national interest in the public
trust do entanglement with foreign
governments and number three abuse of
power by corrupting democratic elections
in denying the people proper agency
through self-government accorded in the
framers any one of these violations of
the public trust would be enough to
justify presidential impeachment for
abuse of power however president Trump's
conduct has realized all three of the
framers worst fears of presidential
abuse of power
never before in American history has an
impeachment investigation crystallized
in findings of conduct that implicate
all of the major reasons that the
framers built impeachment into our
Constitution mr. chairman the conduct we
set before you today is not some kind of
surprising aberration or deviation in
the president's behavior for which he is
remorseful on the contrary the president
is completely unrepentant and defiantly
declares his behavior here perfect
indeed absolutely perfect he says that
article 2 of the Constitution gives him
the power to do whatever he wants
conveniently forgetting article 2
section 4 which gives us the power to
check his misconduct with the instrument
of impeachment we believe this conduct
is impeachable and should never take
place again
under our constitutional system he
believes his conduct is perfect and we
know therefore that it will take place
again and again
indeed our report points out that this
pattern of showing spectacular
disrespect for the rule of law by
inviting and welcoming foreign powers
into our elections was in plain view in
the 2016 presidential election America
remembers when then candidate Donald
Trump uttered the imperishable infamous
words Russia if you're listening I hope
you're able to find the thirty thousand
emails that are missing and just five
hours later Russian agents moved to hack
his political opponents computers as
part of their continuing effort to upend
the 2016 presidential campaign as
identified by the Justice Department the
Trump campaign had more than 100
contacts with Russian operatives over
the course of that campaign and none of
them were reported by the Trump campaign
to law enforcement or national security
agencies moreover during the special
counsel investigation into the sweeping
and systematic Russian campaign to
subvert our election President Trump
engaged in another systematic campaign
of obstruction of the investigative
process to obscure his own involvement
mr. president mr. chairman we present
you not just with high crimes and
misdemeanors but a constitutional crime
in progress up to this very minute
mayor Giuliani the president's private
lawyer fresh from his overseas travel
looking to rehabilitate once again the
discredited conspiracy theories at the
heart of the president's defense
admitted that he participated directly
in the smear campaign to oust ambassador
Jovanovic from her job according to The
New Yorker magazine Giuliani said I
believe that I needed yovanovich out of
the way she was going to make the
investigations difficult for everybody
and here of course mr. Giuliani refers
to the president's sought after
investigations into Joe Biden and the
remnants of the discredited conspiracy
theory pushed by Russia as propaganda
that it was Ukraine and not Russia that
interfered in the 2016 American
presidential election
given that an unrepentant president
considers his behavior perfect given
that he thinks the Constitution empowers
him to do whatever he wants
given that he and his team are still
awaiting president zalenski statement
about investigating Joe Biden given that
he has already invited China to perform
an investigation of its own we can only
given that an unrepentant president
considers his behavior perfect given
that he thinks the Constitution empowers
him to do whatever he wants
given that he and his team are still
awaiting president zalenski statement
about investigating Joe Biden given that
he has already invited China to perform
an investigation of its own we can only
in next the president's continuing
course of conduct constitutes a clear
and present danger to democracy in
America we cannot allow this misconduct
to pass it would be a sellout of our
Constitution our foreign policy our
national security and our democracy
Thank You mr. chairman I yield back
thank you very much mr. Collins welcome
back to the Rules Committee Thank You
mr. chairman it's good to see you and
mr. Cole as well members who have spent
many hours in this room with you know
the chairman made a statement about my
friend here mr. Raskin and he is a fine
attorney and and it's been amazing to me
throughout this year how the Judiciary
Committee has sidelined fine attorneys
like himself into not asking questions
and not being a part of the process it's
been really interesting to watch because
he's actually a good one and as you said
he's a good constitutional attorney I'm
not a constitutional attorney I'm a
pastor and an attorney from North
Georgia but I believe that you take
another to look at this and you can
apply consul lens as well but it's a
common-sense lens it's a common-sense
land mr. Cole made a question a comment
there when he and his opening statements
he says you said mr. Cole has said it
doesn't make sense
yeah it does it makes perfect sense look
at the pattern you know the only thing
that is that is
a clear and present danger right now in
this room is the pattern of attack and
abuse of rules and decisions to get at
this president they started over three
years ago really the night he was
elected and I said the other day and the
committee hearing I talked about you
know that having the means and the
motive and the opportunity the
opportunity for this day occurred last
November when we lost majority it
occurred because they already talked
about it for four years in prior and so
now we just bring it forward and we've
tried a lot of different things to get
there and we'll talk about that I'm sure
is this the time goes on today and look
we can have plenty of time to talk about
the the articles and and the very vague
articles that we did it's pretty
interesting if you read the report from
majority there's a lot of discussion
about crimes but they couldn't find it
in themselves to charge one again common
sense articles and we think about
impeachment you're thinking about
pitching a president in particular for
crimes you're thinking about oh you're
sitting at now and it was it was and
this majority has tried so hard to be
like Clinton and Nixon and failed so
miserably but every time we try we try
once again except the one thing when he
came down to the very end the one thing
they couldn't do is actually find a
crime they talked about it a bunch if
you read their read the majority's
report it is well-written it is some of
the best work you'll see frankly in some
ways of fictional accounts of what this
actually is but it actually talks about
that the problem here is a majority bent
on finding something for this president
mr. Kaul it's not a surprise in fact
it's a sad day for another for the Rules
Committee before the Judiciary Committee
you know it's telling that the articles
of impeachment to show you how partisan
is it and really this concerning part
that I see and mr. McGovern is a friend
and we disagree in you your exact role
we disagree probably own a lot of things
is this glass half-full everything and
that's fine that's what we're supposed
to do that's what our voters send us
here for but to find ways to actually
work well we have work together the
question I have here though is if this
was as your as the speaker said just
supposed to be overwhelming bipartisan
and the
American people understand it then why
are we in the Rules Committee today when
it was with Clinton it was a you see
straight to the floor
it wasn't CAD didn't have to come to the
Rules Committee because both sides could
see there was something needed to be
discussed and that's not true here and
so we're having to bring it up here to
the Rules Committee a place that I have
spent many hours and many of us on this
group have discussed many things but
this is should not be one of them
you know it's interesting and I hear a
lot today and I've heard already from
mr. Raskin and from the from the
Chairman as well discussion of the
founders and it's interesting we cherry
picked the founders and that's okay
that's what you know partisans do when
you're in a partisan impeachment you
cherry-pick the founders if you like
this partisan work yeah if you like the
other partisan but the one that's not
mentioned is the very thing that we're
here for and that was found I believe it
was in Federalist us I think it's 65
who's Hamilton when he said this he said
the founders warned against a vague
open-ended charge because it could be
applied on a partisan fashion by the
majority of the house representatives
against Anna Pappas ition president
Alexander Hamilton called partisan
impeachment regulated by more of the
comparative strength of parties than the
real demonstration of innocence or guilt
the greatest danger and additionally the
founders explicitly excluded the term
maladministration from the impeachment
clause because they did not want the
subject present presidents to the whims
of Congress they're worse James Madison
said so vague a term will be the
equivalent to a tenured during the play
during the pleasure of the Senate and I
would say would be a tenure to the
pleasure of this house when we
understand what's going on here when we
look at the discussions here there are
many things that I want to talk about
but the first I want to do is when we
talk about how we get to a certain place
proper process leads to proper results
and we've not had any of that in this
process I have always said and I've said
it many times in our discussions lately
is that this is all about a clock in a
calendar and has been for a while since
January when we were sworn in is about a
clock in a calendar why do I say that
because we had to get to it by the end
of the year because we went into the
next year it will be really too close
especially from the houses perspectives
to the elections that they're trying to
interfere with and yes they're trying to
interfere with
elections the 2020 election by actually
beginning this process and been going
forward now the conduct is not conducted
the perspex the American people the
clock in the calendar no no masters
except themselves you see our Committee
held its first hearing on December 4th
literally the day after shift publicly
released his report in the first minutes
of the hearing mr. Sensenbrenner
furnished the chairman with our demand
for minority day of hearings the
chairman also set a deadline of December
6 for Republicans and the president to
request additional witnesses but it
wasn't until Saturday the day after the
deadline the chairmanship transmitted
8,000 pages of material to the Judiciary
Committee and we still haven't gotten
everything not that it matters to the
majority for institutionalist this
should bother you you can you can still
go ahead and vote for yes tomorrow and
vote for yesterday and do that but it
shouldn't matter for this institution
that while I was in Georgia I received a
call from my staff saying they've just
released 8,000 documents some drives
some of which were going to be kept in a
secure holding and when I asked the
Chairman about these documents were they
gonna be used he said well we're not
gonna read them either we're not gonna
have a chance to go through them we're
just gonna go ahead with what we're
doing that was from my chairman who I
respect greatly we've done a lot of
things together but it has been very
difficult when in a hearing of this
magnitude how can any one Republican or
Democrat actually go back and look at
their constituents in the face and say
we looked at all the evidence I looked
at everything and I came to this
conclusion
no we cherry-pick the evidence and we
only use what we only do because that
material which by the way is still not
all been released
there's the Inspector General IG report
there's still transmite has not been
released now whether it's good or bad is
irrelevant but when you're talking about
impeaching a president shouldn't the
underlying evidence sent to Judiciary
Committee actually matter again it
doesn't take constitutional experts
coming in and telling us about it it
takes common sense to know that you
don't impeach somebody without at least
making all the evidence proper but you
know that's what happens when you're to
the tyranny of a clock and a calendar
when you're the tyranny of a clock and a
calendar and nothing else matters it's
like what's going to happen here in the
holidays is you're getting close to that
day and yours
suppose to give that gift nothing else
matters you just got to go get it at the
last minute if you don't have anything
mister I bet you've done this you go out
and you just buy the first thing you get
and this is what was happening the clock
was running out so they found a phone
call they didn't like they didn't like
this administration they didn't like
what the president did they tried to
make up claims of it there was pressure
and all these other things that they've
so outlined in the report but at the end
of the day it's simply last minute
Christmas shopping they ran and found
something they said we can do it but no
crimes none in the Articles abuse of
power in which any member can make up
anything they want to in caller and
abuse of power but in the report they
document bribery and extortion and all
these other things which they can't put
into the articles and then the
obstruction of justice again it's sort
of interesting when I just read
chairmanship transferred on a Saturday
8,000 pages of what we're supposed to be
working out for the next hearing we
submitted our list of witnesses to
Nadler the David Adler before the shifts
innocent we submitted it before chef had
sent us any more evidence last Monday we
had a hearing so chef staff and Adler's
consultants could tell us that the
president needs to be impeached
again nothing from chairman Schiff who
had made the reference to himself being
like Ken Starr but for those in this
room who have at least opened a history
book Ken Starr actually came and
testified and took questions from
everyone including the White House
Counsel on Monday the Chairman rejected
are all of our witnesses out of hand and
on Tuesday the morning after the
presentation of articles were unveiled
remember think about this no factual
based witnesses we had a bunch of law
professors one for us by the way I did
ask for another one didn't get it no
reasoning we just went back and we were
in impeachment hearings and we went back
to the normal 3 1 ratio I asked for one
more and basically didn't get it it was
an interesting conversation between the
Chairman and I didn't get then we came
in and got our witness list summarily
dismissed we get information dumped to
us in the middle of what we're supposed
to be doing Rob before we're having to
have hearings before we had to after the
fact we had to turn on our witness list
judge I don't think this will find any
regular normal court proceeding because
I know this is not so
for anybody who wants to tweet or say
anything we're not in a court I know
that we're in a kangaroo court it feels
like in this place because all of this
is backwards what's up is down and down
is up for more Alice in Wonderland then
we are house of representatives because
whether you agree that he needs to be
impeached or not do you not think there
needs to be a modicum a process and
rights all of this is true the rules
completely aside the minority healing
day broken access to committee records
rule broken do you process rights for
the accused in impeachment completely
out the window rules for the corman
debate well we've seen that broken even
on the House floor
h.res 660 the authorization for this
whole thing the Chairman could have used
it to run a fair process unfortunately
we didn't the problem comes down today
is there several things I'm gonna leave
you with mr. chairman and this is it
after all it has been said all that's
been talked about in all of his win that
wonderfully written report there's four
facts that will never change
both the president mr. szalinski say
there was no pressure the call
transcript shows no conditionality in
aid and an investigation by the way mr.
Sanyal and their key witness the only
thing they ever float is his opening
statement they don't like to quote when
he actually was questioned when he said
well yeah I presumed that and then we
talked about mr. Yarmuth mr. Yarmuth
said we didn't have any conversation
about conditionality of aid that was
just coming out just the other day I'm
not sure where we're getting this but
it's definitely wasn't a call transcript
Ukrainians were not aware the aid was
withheld even when the president spoke
and Ukraine's did not open
investigations didn't get a meeting they
don't know why but what did we see last
week and over the past two weeks we saw
mr. szalinski president slansky pillared
in our committee he's either a liar a
pathological liar according to the
majority or he is so weak he shouldn't
even governing that country that's
tragic we actually did that to this
sitting leader world leader in our
committee these are the kind of things
that bother many of us but also I know
this is also on a clock in a calendar to
will have a people hours here we'll talk
about it but I will remind my majority
friends and I do consider you friends
the clock in the calendar are terrible
masters and they lead to awful results
and yes there will be a day of reckoning
the calendar in the clock will
continue but what you do here and how we
have trashed the process and getting
here will live on and it will affect
everything that we've come for and so
whatever you may gain will be
short-lived because the clock in the
calendar also recognize common sense
which is not been used in this
proceeding know that mr. Chairman I
yield back
thank you very much thing I want to
thank both of you for your opening
statements of that mr. College you
raised the issue of why we're here in
the Rules Committee today and let me
just say for the record that as you know
the Constitution gives the house to sole
power of impeachment and the power to
determine its own rules
you know when President Nixon during the
time he was going to be impeached the
chairman of the Rules Committee Chairman
Madden actually spoke on the House floor
and announced that there would be a rule
governing how that proceeding would move
forward when the Clinton articles of
impeachment were brought forward there
was a unanimous consent request to kind
of govern how we conducted ourselves and
I'm not sure how likely it would be that
we would get a unanimous consent request
I'd like to ask unanimous consent
without objection to enter into a record
a letter that was sent to the chairman
of the Judiciary Committee signed by I
think 70 Republican members including
the Kevin McCarthy the Republican leader
and basically let me read the key line
here is we will avail ourselves of every
parliamentary tool available to us in
committee and on the House floor the
highlight your inaction translated means
to try to delay and to make this process
is impossible as it can be made I'm not
sure in light of this letter that we
could get a unanimous consent request
with regard to these proceedings to
break for a cup of coffee never mind you
know determine the rules of engagement
so I'd point that out in terms of
process I just want to again stay for
the record because I think it's
important that I think the house is
engaged in a fair impeachment inquiry
process Democrats and Republicans have
had equal opportunity to participate in
the month-long impeachment inquiry
members of both parties have been
involved at every stage in this process
from sitting in and asking questions and
closed-door depositions
to questioning witnesses and open
hearings the committee's took more than
a hundred hours of deposition testimony
from 17 witnesses held seven public
hearings which included Republican
requested witnesses they produced a 300
page public report that laid out their
findings at evidence the Judiciary
Committee then took that report and
conducted two public hearings evaluating
the evidence and legal standard for
impeachment before reporting the two
articles that we are dealing with here
today and I should also point out the
President Trump was provided an
opportunity for to participate in the
Judiciary Committee's review of the
evidence presented against him as
President Clinton was during his
impeachment inquiry president Trump
chose not to participate President Trump
to date has not provided any escalatory
evidence but instead has blocked
numerous witnesses from testifying about
his actions and so I just thought was
important to point that out
mr. mr. ask and I saw you scribbling
furiously while mr. Collins was
testifying I don't know whether there's
something that you wanted to respond to
well Thank You mr. chairman my friend
mr. Collins speaks very fast so it's
hard to keep up with everything that
he's saying a couple of things did from
Massachusetts and people say the same
thing about my accent so I give you
better than you were making an effort at
the beginning and so was I so they
accused me of this same let me let me he
raises some really important points and
I've loved the chance to briefly address
them the one thing that we've been
hearing is that we didn't charge crimes
and in some sense that just duplicates a
basic confusion that people have about
what the process is we are not criminal
prosecutors prosecuting a criminal
defendant in court to send to jail
that's not what we're doing we're
members of Congress who are working to
protect the country against a president
who's committing high crimes and
misdemeanors that is constitutional
offenses against the people of the
country now lots of the con
that we plead in our specific articles
alleging abuse of power and obstruction
of Congress to themselves could become
part of criminal indictments later on
but it's been a curious thing for me to
hear our colleagues across the aisle
repeatedly make this point and kind of
spread this confusion that they're not
crimes in there when they were the very
first ones to be saying and continue to
say the Department of Justice cannot
prosecute the president the President
may not be indicted the President may
not be prosecuted while he's in office
that's the position they take they then
cannot turn around say oh and you can't
impeach him because you haven't charged
him with any crimes and prosecuted him
and indicted him you see heads I win
tails you lose
is the essence of that argument and of
course if you go back to the the Richard
Nixon case we didn't have to see that
Richard Nixon had been convicted of
burglary in the District of Columbia by
ordering the break-in to the Watergate
Hotel before he was at shoes but before
he was charged with abuse of power as a
high crime and misdemeanor that's
exactly what we're charging President
Trump with here we don't have to first
go out and prove that he committed
bribery or committed honest services
fraud or committed extortion all things
that he really could be prosecuted for
later we simply have to allege the the
course of constitutional criminal
conduct he was engaged in and so I think
that we can set that one aside a second
thing that that my friend said was that
there were no fact witnesses that that
this was based on the report that was
delivered to us by the House Committee
on Intelligence and of course that's a
play on words too there were 17 fact
witnesses who appeared before the House
Committee on Intelligence the House
Oversight Committee and the House
Foreign Affairs to me the way that we
structured this impeachment process
which is completely our prerogative
under article 1 section 2 Clause 5 is
you said mr. chairman is to have the
fact investigation into this affair
which involve foreign governments and
ambassadors and so on in the
Intelligence Committee then to have them
bring the facts in a comprehensive
report to the House Judiciary Committee
which would then make
the decision about the law do all of
these events rise to what we think is
impeachable conduct and of course we did
so there are lots of fact witnesses the
fact we we also had the Council for the
House Intelligence Committee come in to
deliver the report and defend the report
and all of my friends on the other side
of the aisle had the chance to question
as we had the chance to question when
you say there were no fact witnesses
that's also a perfect description of
what took place during the Bill Clinton
impeachment because all of that took
place as part of the Independent Counsel
investigation by Kenneth Starr there
were closed-door secret depositions
taking place there
then Kenneth Starr came to deliver the
report and member all the boxes of
material they brought over in a u-haul
truck and gave it to the House Judiciary
Committee that was the end of it Monica
Lewinsky didn't testify before the House
Judiciary Committee there were not
witnesses who had been there who were
brought before the House Judiciary
Committee so we're following the exact
same pattern I think that took place
there except that it was the House of
Representatives here which did its own
fact investigation through this
assortment of committees finally the
well the let me just say a word about
the fairness of the process and you know
we all know what they teach you in law
school which is if the facts are against
you you pound the law the laws are
against you you pound the facts if the
law and the facts are against you you
talk about process and you pound the
table
and I'm afraid I've seen a little bit of
that in the performance of our
colleagues here and I don't blame them
because they're dealing with the hand
that they were dealt we have 17 fact
witnesses and all of their depositions
and all their testimony was published
all part of the report everybody
everybody can find it and all of their
testimony is essentially unrefuted and
uncontradicted it tells one story which
is the President of the United States
conducted a shakedown of a foreign power
he used 391 million dollars that we in
Congress had voted for a
sieged struggling democracy Ukraine to
defend itself against Russian invasion
and attack to coerce that the president
of that foreign government president
zalenski to get involved in our election
campaign what did he want him to do well
he wanted president szalinski to make an
announcement on television that Joe
Biden was being investigated now what
does that have to do with the foreign
policy of the United States what does it
have to do with what Congress voted for
what does it have to do with any
legitimate interest of the US government
but the other thing that he wanted
presidents Lenski to do was to
rehabilitate the completely discredited
conspiracy theory that it was Ukraine
and not Russia that had interfere in our
election our entire intelligence
community the NSA the CIA the FBI the
Senate Committee on Intelligence issued
a report about this all of them say the
same thing which is that it was Russia
that conducted what the Department of
Justice called a sweeping and systematic
campaign against our election in 2016
you remember mr. chairman they injected
propaganda into our polity through
social media Facebook and Twitter and so
on they directly conducted cyber
invasion and attack and espionage
against the Democratic National
Committee the d-triple-c Hillary
Clinton's headquarters and they directly
tried to get into our state boards of
Elections not two or three all 50 of
them they tried to get into that's what
Russia did and now suddenly we have the
president United States telling
President Solinsky that if he wants the
391 million dollars that we voted for
him and that he's been certified for by
the Department of Defense in the
Department of State clearing every anti
corruption screen that had been put in
place and called for by Congress if he
wants the money and if he wants the
White House meeting that he desperately
wanted to show that America was on
Ukraine's side and not Russia side if he
wanted to get that stuff he had to come
and get involved in our presidential
campaign and he had to rehabilitate this
discredited story about 2016 he'll back
well
thank you you know I think I've been
listening some of the commentary and
then the news from the pundits and
sometimes I think people need a lesson
in constitutional law that's why it's
great that you're here let me ask you a
basic question because I think sometimes
people don't or since
why is impeachment in the Constitution
oh that's a great question
and mr. Collins invoked indirectly my
favorite American revolutionary Tom
Paine who of course wrote common sense
and the age of reason and he said you
can't have one without the other in
other words you need the common sense of
the people and you need people to be
conducting things according to reason
rationality facts empiricism science but
why did Paine come all the way over here
to participate in the American
Revolution which was not forward aimed
to win in any way because America was
the first nation in history born out of
a revolutionary struggle against
monarchy against the idea that you could
have hereditary rule Paine said a
hereditary a hereditary ruler is as
ridiculous as a hereditary mathematician
or hereditary artist right he said the
people have got to decide on their own
leaders now impeachment is an instrument
that our founders put into the
Constitution informed by the British
experience there was impeachment that
Parliament had but it wasn't against the
king it was only against royal ministers
why because of the British doctrine the
King can do no wrong right that's kind
of like the king can do whatever he
wants the King can do no wrong and
therefore the king could implement each
but our founders insisted that
impeachment be in there not just for
other civil officers who might commit
high crimes and misdemeanors against the
people but against the President himself
and of course the president in the
domestic emoluments clause is limited to
a fixed salary in office which can be
neither increase nor decrease by
Congress and he can't receive any other
emoluments from the government's help
and any other payments the president is
effectively an employee of the American
people that's the way he's designed he's
not above the people he's a servant of
the people like all of us are and the
president's core job is what
to take care that the laws are
faithfully executed and if he doesn't
faithfully execute the laws if he
thoughts the laws if he tramples the
laws and he commits crimes against
American people then we're not going to
send him to prison he's nothing to jail
for one day but he needs to be removed
in order to protect demise and for the
record why is abuse of power and
impeachable offense well abuse of power
is the essential impeachment offense
that's why it's in there
what it's about is elevating the
personal interests and ambitions of the
president above the common good
above the rule of law and above the
constitution and so the the founders
didn't want a president who was going to
behave like a king we'd seen enough of
that we wanted a president who was gonna
implement the laws go out and you know
implement the Affordable Care Act and
implement the environmental law so
that's your job you know that's what
you're supposed to be doing and so we've
seen evidence of the president decided
to withhold from Ukraine important
official acts the White House visit
military aid in order to pressure
Ukraine to announce it as sedation's of
Vice President Biden and the 2016
elections why does that constitute an
impeachable offense so well it basically
implicates every single one of the
concerns that were raised by the
founders at the Constitutional
Convention one it places the personal
political agenda and additions of the
president over enforcing the laws and
enforcing the rule of law two it drags
foreign powers into our election that
was something that the framers were
terrified about there was a a great
exchange between Adams and Jefferson
about just this issue that there would
be constant foreign intrigue and
influence attempts to come and influence
because we would be an open democracy
and so people would try to exploit our
openness by getting involved in our
elections with their foreign government
concerns which is why the President had
to have complete undivided loyalty to
the American people into the American
Constitution and not get involved with
foreign governments not drive foreign
governments into our affairs so
basically you have everything to the
framers were concerned about tied up
into one bundle here which is in
in foreign governments in our elections
placing the the president's interests
over all of the over everything else and
then essentially threatening the rule of
the people in democracy and and and
where do you draw the line between a
legitimate use of presidential power and
an abuse of power I mean and and why is
it significant that President Trump
acted for his personal political
advantage and not for the furtherance of
any valid national policy objective
that's a great question because our
colleagues have shrewdly zeroed in on
the fact that some of the witnesses
including ambassador Salman said well of
course there was a quid pro quo the
president was not going to release the
aid he was not gonna have the meeting
until he got what he wanted in terms of
political interference and then even the
president's what else chief of staff
said yes of course there was a quid pro
quo I'm not quoting directly so I don't
have the exact words but he's saying yes
this is this is the way we proceed get
used to it okay and our colleagues have
said well there's always quid pro quos
tied up in foreign policy in other words
it's legit to say to a foreign
government we will give you this aid if
you comply that the aid is all being
used in the proper way we will give you
this assistance if you attend these
conferences and meetings with us to make
sure that the assistance is being used
properly and so on there's nothing wrong
with that but look at what happened here
this was this was an arrangement where
the president conditioned all of this
foreign assistance that we had sent 200
million dollars to the Department of
Defense the defence 191 million dollars
to the Department of State to help
Ukraine defend itself against Russia and
the president said but I but what he was
holding out for was the interference of
the Ukrainian fries the president in our
election to harm his political opponent
and I think everyone can recognize that
is not the normal kind of push and pull
and arrangements that nations make for
each other why because the president
privileged his own political interest
and that's why it was all done secretly
luckily there were witnesses were
willing to come forward and to explain
what happened mr. Collins
you attend this reskins the same
question I mean was the president's call
with president Solinsky perfect as the
president has said and was it
appropriate for him to ask another
country to investigate an American
citizen I thought there was nothing I
said as for there's nothing wrong with a
call and then when you look at it and
again I'm frankly the last the problem
having right now is is exactly the last
15 minutes of this great oratory on a
lot of things that mean nothing to this
actual impeachment I mean if we get down
to the bottom line here and and I'm just
leave it at that let him answer that
question I'll get back to it later
because everything has been thrown out
here is exactly what the problem we've
had in the discussion and this idea of
throwing wall in fact we've just proven
the facts we've talked about the law
wall and Brogan didn't put it in the
country so I'm not I can yell on both of
them I talk about both of them problem
we have here is is this is the very
problem we have and I'll just address
one thing before I let about or or if
you want me to switch right now well I
mean I'll give a damn I mean yeah that's
fine I mean I'm looking at you know the
president yeah in the transcript see I
would like you to do us a favor though I
mean I do you think was a perfect call
lieutenant Carl bellman acts that is
perfectly okay for the president past
for political alcohol and I can actually
it was in his Testament yeah and do you
think it's all learn to cook dinner call
them and said would it ever be it was
asked what everybody US policy in your
experience to ask a foreign leader to
open a political investigation you
provide certainly the president arrived
to do that I mean do you think it's
right for the president of the SEO firm
they were meant to investigate a US
citizen like that no I think it's
absolutely wrong and you know one of the
interesting things about the hearings of
course was that that every single I
think every single member of Congress
who has at least endorse the impeachment
inquiry has said that it's completely
wrong for the US president to use any of
the means at his disposal to drag
foreign governments into our election
and we were unable to get our colleagues
on the Judiciary Committee to weigh in
on that saying let's assume that you
think let's stipulate you think that the
President did nothing wrong here do you
think it's wrong for the president
United States to get foreign powers
involved in our election and we couldn't
get an answer I reassured the invitation
to mr. Collins because I I believe that
in his heart he thinks that's wrong and
I certainly would not want
to become the pattern for all future
presidencies I think the interesting
thing here this year if I could I would
I don't want this to become the pattern
for future impeachments I think this is
the problem I have any and then the
understanding here is I guess it's okay
though to get involved in a 2016
election when you pay a third party to
go pay for a dossier I mean these are
the kind of things we can talk about but
the interesting issue that is just
discussed here is exactly where we are
right now in a question in the comment
because the what mr. Raskin just brought
up is an interesting point so is it okay
if you're running for president that you
can't be investigated even if you did
something overseas so if you were
running for president and you did
something overseas it would be it would
be off limits according to mr. askins
argument for the United States
government to investigate that that's
the argument he just set up now think
can you be very careful with that
argument I appreciate I guess again I
mentioned this in my opening statement
the frustrating thing is that it's hard
I mean I would seem so obvious to so
many of us about inappropriate behavior
we can't even get I mean I look at you
know our former colleague Charlie dent
says he spoke over Republicans were
absolutely disgusted and exhausted by
the president's behavior another former
Republican colleague of ours david jolly
said with witness quote in impeachable
moment former republican congressman
Reid Ribble of wisconsin said clearly
there was some type of quid pro quo when
asked if he believes the testimony
presented Warren's impeachment he said I
do former South Carolina Republican Bob
Inglis who served on the Judiciary
Committee during the clinton
ministration said last month in a tweet
without a doubt if Barack Obama had done
the things revealed in the testimony in
the and the current inquiry Republicans
would have impeached him Joe Scarborough
former Republican congressman from
Florida said every Republican knows that
Donald Trump was asking for dirt on Joe
Biden in exchange for releasing military
funds I mean I well let's let's go on to
I know you want to respond mr. ruskin
sure I'd be delighted to but one thing
I've just passed a note saying I may
have gotten the numbers wrong the drone
of defense had to a 250 million dollar
appropriation for the purposes of aiding
Ukraine and the state had 141 million I
may have spoken to another
but but you know as to that point I
again I feel for my friends because I
think they're put into a situation put
into a box so to speak which was what
President Trump was quoted as saying
about what he wanted to do with
president Solinsky he wanted him in a
box about statements but I think they're
put into something of a corner here
because the president has declared his
conduct perfect absolutely perfect and
he can do whatever he wants and so they
are unable to say to make the case that
I would make is value if I were trying
to defend the president I would say okay
that was totally wrong and off-limits
but it's not impeachable for x y&z
reasons but they're not allowing anybody
that space to say they must go with the
president's assertion that this was
categorically correct there was nothing
wrong with it it was perfectly right and
you know he quoted legal scholars he
didn't name them that he invoked legal
scholars who told him that the call was
perfect as well and I want to move my
question along here a little bit so let
me let me add the issue of instruction
of Congress why is obstruction of
Congress an impeachable offense well
look this is something mr. Collins made
a really important point which is that
we've got to think about this in
institutional terms okay and he rightly
calls us to redouble our commitment to
fairness in the process I've seen lots
of fairness in this process I've seen
the in in the closed-door depositions I
saw the Democratic counsel get an hour
I saw the Republican counsel get an hour
I saw the Democratic members get to
questions I saw the Republican members
get to question I have seen this
committee bend over backwards to get all
of the depositions out as quickly as
possible while the president United
States is stopping at least seven
witnesses from coming forward it may be
more than that but he has blockaded
witnesses the president who says the
process is unfair is the one who's
stopping everybody from coming to
testify and is essentially trying to
blockade the whole investigation look
why is this essential mr. chairman it's
essential because for institutional
reasons it's a central for institutional
reasons because in the future it might
be a majority democratic
might be a majority Republican Congress
but in any event its Congress and one of
our jobs is as members of Congress is to
make sure that the president does not
violate the laws we're supposed to stand
Sentinel to make sure that the president
will only enforce the laws take care
that the laws are faithfully executed
well what happens if you get a president
who totally trashes the law okay some of
us think we may be there now I know some
of our colleagues don't believe that but
certainly they can imagine a situation
where a president advertises spectacular
disrespect and contempt for the law and
trashes the law what is our ultimate
Chuck against that it's going to be
impeachment that's why it's in the
Constitution
but now we have a president who for the
first time in American history says I am
going to try to block the ability of
Congress to impeach me by not turning
over one single document by trying to
hold back people from testifying like
secretary
Pompeyo like chief of staff Mick
Mulvaney like multiple other members of
administration I don't want them to come
forward to testify and so we're gonna
have to use our common sense to derive
conclusions about what that means out
whoa what does our common sense tell us
when you have all these other people
were coming forward and testifying about
the misconduct of the President and then
the president trying to block everybody
else from coming forward to testify in
his administration and let me just point
out for the record we've requested
several documents in testimony for
members of this administration and what
is the president is administration done
the response
nothing just I think it's important for
people understand this for the record
request for documents from the State
Department ignored requests for
documents from the Department of Defense
ignored requests for documents from the
vice president ignored requests for
documents from Giuliani associate level
partners ignored requests from documents
from Giuliani associated Igor fruit
crewmen ignored requests from document
from the White House ignored requests
from documents from Rudy Giuliani the
president's lawyer ignored requests from
testimony of former national security
adviser john bolton ignored requests
from the testimony of White House chief
of staff Mick Mulvaney ignored and
here's a list of all
the request has been made the red marks
are basically to demonstrate
non-compliance that if they have been
ignored I think this is what you call
obstruction plain and simple and in fact
the only people that have complied with
our requests have been patriotic public
servants many of them defying
instructions that they not comply and I
mean I guess I've just asked you know
what presumptions should we make when
the president where the president
prevents witness from witnesses from
complying with congressional subpoenas
well let's use our common sense people
who have exculpatory evidence which is
just a fancy way of saying evidence that
shows their innocence want the court to
see the evidence people who have
evidence that demonstrates their
innocence would bring that to Congress
people who have evidence which they
think may be inculpatory people of
evidence which may lead people to
believe in their guilt will try to keep
it away but you just make a really
profoundly important point mr. chairman
which link articles one an article two
of the impeachment articles do we want
to set a precedent that people that US
citizens can become president of the
United States by inviting foreign powers
to get involved in our election then
once they're in if Congress decides that
their conduct is impeachable and
involves high crimes and misdemeanors
they can then pull curtain down over the
executive branch and not allow any
investigation not allow subpoenas to be
honored and so on that is a very
dangerous prospect that would have
terrified and horrified and shocked the
framers of our Constitution thank you
and I you you want to okay
well I'm about to I'm about to yield to
my to the my ranking member I'm sure has
lots and lots of questions but I do I do
want to take a moment I think it's
important that we remember this I want
to remind everybody why we're here today
the president abused the power of his
office for his own personal gain and
obstructed a congressional investigation
to look into that content how did he do
that he withheld aid for a country that
was under siege by Russia to leverage
help for his political campaign
president Trump's abuse of power has
endangered our free elections and
national security remains an ongoing
threat to them both he showed us a
pattern of inviting foreign interference
in our elections and is and trying to
cover it up twice and he's tried to do
it again with the 2020 elections fast
approaching we must act with a sense of
urgency to protect our democracy and
defend our Constitution you know our
first day as members of Congress we took
an oath to support and defend the
Constitution of the United States
against all enemies foreign and domestic
I did not swear allegiance to a
political party I swore allegiance of
the Constitution and I hope all my
colleagues will do the same with that I
would yield to the ranking mr. Cole for
any questions you may have thank you
very much mr. chairman and you're right
I do have a lot of questions and I
appreciate your forbearance because it's
a very liberal yes you are and in this
sense in the finest sense of the word so
I expressed my appreciation for that at
times we've discussed and to my friend
mr. Raskin
a number of my questions have been
crafted or were originally crafted for
chairman Adler you may or may not be
able to answer those directly we
certainly understand why he's not here
and we as the chairman said we
sympathize with him in a difficult time
but we think they're still important for
the record I just wanted wanted to sort
of highlight that for you mr. Chairman I
ask unanimous consent to enter into the
record a document entitled quote how we
resist from unquote authored by
Congressman Jerry Nadler and posted on
wwe.com on November 16th of 2016 without
objection
Thank You mr. chairman in this document
chairman adler wrote quote we cannot
wait for years to vote mr. Trump out of
office so we must do everything we can
to stop Trump and his extreme agenda now
unquote mr. Raskin on August 8th
chairman Adler stated with respect to
the Judiciary Committee's hearing
regarding the Mullah report that quote
this is a formal impeachment proceedings
but the house unquote but the house did
not actually authorize impeachment
proceedings until the adoption of h.res
six six zero on October 31st so believe
it's important to clarify for the record
when formal impeachment proceedings
actually started this chairman Nadler
correct when he said they started on
August 8th or did they begin when the
house authorized them on October 31st
forgive me whoa I was not actually
prepared to answer that question but I
think that the Judiciary Committee has
taken formal positions which we can
track about this question I would just
direct you to
again article 1 section 2 Clause 5 the
House of Representatives is the sole
power of impeachment and can design and
structure impeachment as it sees fit
well it's not without passing a
resolution it didn't gives them power
and authority that goes outside of House
Rules that's the problem we had with
this overall is they were going outside
of House Rules and again when councils
are not you know been here forever they
were trying to make this happen is what
happens here they went outside of House
Rules
that's that's the problem I've had with
this and we can discuss that more in
depth and I think the spirit behind this
suggests that this has been going on for
quite some time longer than the formal
proceedings mr. Creston on December 10th
1998 during the Clinton impeachment
proceedings chairman Nadler stated in
the House Judiciary Committee that quote
there must never be a narrowly voted
impeachment or an impeachment supported
by one of our major political parties
and opposed by another such an
impeachment will produce divisive 'no
sand bitterness and politics for years
to come and will call into question the
very legitimacy of our political
institutions and do you believe that
this impeachment which is supported by
only one political party has produced
bitterness in the current political
climate so well I'm again I'm gonna have
to allow the chairman Adler to speak for
his own worth I certainly understand
yeah so look there there's been a lot of
bitterness and division in our country
for several years now proceeding any
impeachment proceedings and it's a sad
thing and I hope that everybody rallies
around the Constitution because it's the
Constitution that will get us through
this difficult time in our history and
let me just say about you know the
Clinton impeachment so the the conduct
that President Clinton was charged with
which was he hadn't been convicted or
prosecuted for perjury but he was he was
essentially charged with murdering
himself in describing private conduct a
sexual affair and the conduct that we're
looking at today goes right to the heart
of why impeachment is in the
Constitution impeachment is in the
Constitution because of public offenses
by political leaders against democracy
itself so I think you cannot compare
what President Clinton was impeached for
by the House of Representatives and I
hold no brief for his conduct in any way
but I don't think you can compare that
to the massive overwhelming and
unrefuted evidence we have that the
president of United States today has
tried to drag a foreign power into our
elections to his own political advantage
wasn't exactly the question I asked but
let me turn to mr. Collins and see if
you agree with mr. Raskin there anything
you would disagree with there and what's
been the impact of this process on the
domestic politics of the country since
it has been essentially partisan in
nature look not trying to you know in
again I'll cut some slack that he was
trying to answer for a Chairman's own
words and I get that but I think there's
several things it's let's just talk your
for just eventless this let's unpack
what has happened here because the only
thing I appreciate I'm really out of the
whole last few minutes was the chairman
trying to bring it into about
impeachment I agree with him on to that
point that this is about impeachment
what I disagree is it's not about abuse
of power it's not everything else and it
would scent come a lot better from
majority if they have not had a long
history a written record this is
something that you love to see in the
law because it's a written record of
motive you've seen it since the day that
he was elected you've seen it in this
whole process working out you saw it
last year when my Chairman ran for the
job because he would be the best friend
Pietschmann what was hanging out last
year for impeachment what became a de
Mol report that didn't give them
everything they wanted and then we came
into a call this is this is a pattern
and look yea I've said this to my
chairman who I respect you've got the
votes in just vote you got the votes
didn't go explain it to the American
people
talk about talk about afflicting an
election this is what what we're looking
at but there are some few things here
though that is interesting as I said
earlier on time and clock or terrible
masters and I've heard it so many times
from the chairman of this committee the
chairman of my committee and others
we've got to do this because of the 2020
election well put a Canada grabbed
that's worth voting for how about that
instead of going after a president who
you're having trouble completing because
of the things that have happened our
country with unemployment with the
economy going good and everything else
that's what political primaries are for
not this when you look back in and I get
still never got a quite answer to my
question I had just a few minutes ago
about have we now set a standard that if
you run for president you can do
anything you want to overseas and not
get investigated for it not got that
question answered but in response to
also the Chairman's question about
requesting stuff as the chairman knows
and also my chairman knows because my
Chairman likes subpoenas he likes to
threaten him anyway
but the secretary defense responded he
said it was open to negotiation for you
secretary of state part of the document
dump was part of that and the house
tradition committee the dump that we did
get from the intones committee had OMB
record from the Budget Committee in it I
mean their issues here that I have had
problems with all year in this and you
know if you didn't receive a letter as
we have done in the past when we're in a
majority under President Obama and on
President Obama
in fast and furious and other times the
thing that amazes me is that it seems
like the majority this year all of a
sudden discovered that the executive
branch and the legislative branch don't
play well together in the sandbox this
is not a shock for any of us who've been
here under the Obama administration we
saw this happen over and over I was on
Oversight my first two years here my
former late
slative director is here she's in the
room we pulled our hair out of this is
when IRS we had everything else in we
was bit constantly being stonewalled and
stopped
had to actually issue subpoenas in which
finally the courts did rule and they'll
think this is your problem the court
ruled many years later that the Attorney
General Holder did violate you know not
giving the information out and that was
actually done but it was many years
later again your time and clock is that
carrot calendar is a terrible master and
you're having to do this because you
promised it you promised it this is
we're carrying through on a promise here
you know the other thing is we talk
about fairness here that that my friend
said that oh this has been completely
fair and nobody's questioned the fact
that our folks got to question the
witness nobody's questioned that fact
they call but what about the fact of the
majority preventing witnesses under
rules from using agency counsel even
under the auspices of an impeachment
investigation how about cutting off
Republican questions and refusing to
allow the third branch out to even rule
on claims of privilege when one was
actually done you actually would drew
from the lawsuit so again it's not a
matter of time here it's not a matter of
fact again when we go back to it I can't
not repeat this over and over again
because it comes up with mr. assets
coming over the chairman will come up
again many other times put pressure on a
world leader I thought this pressure is
is amazing me because the guy who was
supposed to being pressured denied it
ever happened on multiple occasions one
of his own members of cabinet said we
never talked about conditioning harmik
said we never talked about
conditionality of aid the only times
that they talked about this outside of
presumption in hearsay presumption in
here say their main that witness
sundaland said it was presumption that's
what i presumed because when you
actually ask the president straight up
what do you want he said I want nothing
I just want him to do what he what he
promised in Iran oh that's all I did so
it's presumption here cite and granted
this is not a court of law because
believe me this was been over a long
time ago we would have gotten to this
place the rules have allowed it to get
to this place close majority rules in
this in this place but here's the
problem the pressure issue is sad
because again to continue this line of
thought after the president of the
Ukraine has came out and denied it and
denied it and denied it and denied it
you're either calling him a pathological
liar a world leader
you're calling as was actually he was
actually called in our committee last
week a battered wife he was actually
called bad compared to a battered wife
how low have we sunk this is the problem
because at the end of the day and we can
go into a process file as we can go into
everything else but you know something I
made I don't say some mistake but I took
my own chairman at his work when I read
about his comments from 20 years ago
when he said the judiciary committee
should never take a report from a third
party and actually not try to
investigate it itself otherwise we've
become a rubber-stamp
congratulations our Judiciary Committee
became a rubber-stamp I hope we recover
because that's all we're doing right now
he's just rubber stamping what Adam
Schiff did under his own rules under his
own time for him under his own ways
again a man who has also been out for
this president since day one it would
not come and testify that's the most
amazing shocking thing to me in this
whole process but when you understand
where we're at here I can understand why
mister asking who is eloquent in his
discussion of Constitution why we have
an impeachment let's just cut to the
fact you don't like the guy you don't
like the conversation you don't like how
he does business because at the end of
the day when you start talking about the
pressure on a foreign power to do
something for you personal again we're
to even get to that remotely you're
having to change words in the transcript
instead of do us a favor for our country
do us you have to change to me you have
to change the facts and the last time I
checked this country is not real kind to
those who are accused having those who
are in power change the rules to fit
their game that's not due process but
I'm gonna go back over it because the
chairman actually said here's why we're
here there are four facts that never
change four facts that will never change
and it goes straight to the heart of
anything said outside of abuse power
anything there's no pressure
president Trump president Lansky the
transcript shows no conditionality of
aid and an investigation and the only
one relied upon over 600 times in the
Intelligence Committee report was mr.
sanguine who after he got past his
perfect opening statement when question
said well that's what I presumed it to
be and they wouldn't actually talked to
the president the United States he was
told no all I wanted us to do his job
nothing
and then when he actually said I had a
conversational mr. Yarmuth mr. Yarmuth
said there was nothing discussed of
conditionality so how can you put this
much faith in mr. Sundlun
when he has conditionally told stories
that change and all of the rest were
hearsay all of the rest were actually
going off of other things and even the
kernel ving man who is trucko who I
respect as a as a soldier actually said
when the question was asked is it okay
to have this call said yes it's okay for
a president can do that to ask for a
political investigation because it
happens and he even said that so the
question comes back the Ukrainians were
not even aware of their aid was withheld
and Ukraine's didn't open an
investigation to get the money yes you
is this the first partisan impeachment
inquiry in the nation's history yes
does the president ever been impeached
without votes from the Nora tea party
before I think there was there's some
discussion about that with the Johnson
impeachment for many years ago that was
also when the Congress itself set him up
with a law so I think you have to say
that was an impeachment this is the in a
modern day year this is a partisan
impeachment and March of this year
speaker Pelosi said a Pietschmann must
be quote compelling and overwhelmingly
bipartisan only Democrats voted to
authorize the impeachment inquiry
there's bipartisan opposition to the
inquiry and appears they'll be
bipartisan opposition to the articles
ranking member Collins given all of that
do you believe the upcoming vote on hrs
7:55 comports with the standards set by
the speaker or cell no it comes nowhere
close as your belief that the meeting
and arbitrary deadlines were more
important to the Democratic majority
than building a viable case if in fact
there is cause for impeachment their own
words convict them of that the premise
these articles of impeachment rests on a
pause placed on Ukrainian security
assistance applause by the way of less
than two months 55 days I believe
Democrats have spun creative narratives
as to the meaning and the motive of this
pause but offered no factual evidence
did Ukraine ever initiate investigations
into the Biden's no was the aide
ultimately released yes you
believe the taxpayer dollars of the
American people were well served by the
pause they weren't by the President
himself not policymakers not
administrative officials in different
offices are not the ones who have final
authority to decide if that is gonna be
that's the president's call this the
president's decision and he made a call
is it unusual for aid to be paused on my
chief executive no and I did the
Democratic majority subpoena all core
witnesses with firsthand evidence on any
potential quid pro quo with the Ukranian
controversy no has anyone the Trump
administration been charged with or
convicted of a crime under the current
allegations related to the Ukraine don't
let me continue it's my understanding
that the minority properly exercised his
right under Clause 2 J 1 of rule 11 to
demand a minority hearing is that the
case that is correct
what day did you ask for that hearing we
asked for it on the first day of when we
convened in the Judiciary Committee I
believe that was missing I don't
remember the dates in front of me he's
right in front of it so I'll be happy to
provide that as that hearing been
scheduled no it was summarily dismissed
but a long letter which was told that in
essence that it was dilatory I've never
seen it commit I'm an art hearing called
dilatory on the very first day the
request could have been made mr. Raskin
are you familiar with the following
statement the minorities entitled to one
additional day of related hearings at
which to call their own witnesses if a
majority of the minority members make
their demand before the committee's
hearing is gavel closed I believe I
think mr. Collins invoked that at our
hearing not so you are familiar with
yeah I'm just familiar from that
actually it wasn't aware of it before
the statements posted on the rules
majority website and the document
entitled quote house rules which govern
the committee hearing process unquote
based on review of the hearing video the
minority properly presented their
request to chairman Nadler before the
original hearing concluded are you
familiar
with a memo written by former mr. Raskin
I'm sorry
they don't clear by former Rules
Committee Chairman David Dreier
regarding the application of the house
rule governing the minority hearing dead
no okay
Kara McGovern I asked unanimous consent
that this memo be made part of the
record and will note that the memo
states in part that a point of order may
lie against the reported measure in
which the minorities demand for hearing
was improperly rejected without
objection ask unanimous consent if I can
to also ensure it in the record our
response to your letter and we could
talk about that after your question
certainly appropriate Thank You mr.
chairman
during the mark-up of hrs seven five
five chairman Nadler overruled the
ranking members point of order against
consideration of the resolution and
interpreting that the rule requires that
the minority hearing day occur prior to
the consideration of the relevant
measure or matter would permit them an
or D to improperly delay proceedings are
you trying to improperly delay
proceedings mr. Collins no I was
actually at one point in these hearings
actually have a proper following of
rules so again this you made this
request the very first day of hearings
that correct we did the hearing at which
the demand was properly made was
entitled in part quote the impeachment
inquiry of Donald J Trump unquote my
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle have offered a number of reasons
why chairman Adler's refusal to schedule
the minority hearings appropriate I'd
like to take a moment to respond to
those my colleagues claim that the
legislative history of the rule suggests
that it was designed as a backstop to
ensure the minority gets at least one
witness at a hearing I do not find this
reason to be compelling if that indeed
was the purpose of the rule the plain
reading of the text and reason itself
would say otherwise while traditionally
it's been used as a negotiating point
between the majority and minority
regarding the number of witnesses the
mere fact that the minority has a
witness of the hearing does not mean
that there's an implicit waiver of the
right to demand the minority day hearing
there are times in which the minority
waives the right to a majority day
hearing
our discussions regarding
medicare-for-all hearing we waived that
right to a minority day hearing in order
to secure two more witnesses mr. Collins
at any time did you waive your rights
under Clause 2 J 1 of rule 11 no I did
not and I believe that's why we're here
today actually yeah did you request a
second whit's to stay and did they
provide that second witness a second
witness excuse me and did they provide
that second witness in exchange for
waiving your rights for minority day
hearing no was not even discussed okay
my colleagues on the other side of the
aisle have previously quoted Joint
Committee on the organization of
Congress in 1966 recommendations which
stated that a minimum safeguard be
established for those infrequent
incidents when a witness representing
the minority position are not a lot of
time perhaps in 1966 majority was more
willing to provide witnesses to the
minority however that's not the case
today
witness there was a lot of time in this
case but not witnesses in other words we
didn't get anything in exchange for our
right not being exercised and while this
may have been one reason for the
adoption of the minority hearing Day
provision it doesn't render meaningless
the plain reading of the text so we've
spent a lot of time on this but we think
it's very important we simply weren't
given something that we think by you
know by right we should have had and
would actually subject this to a point
of order my colleagues also claimed
cherylin and was not required to
schedule the minority hearing day before
the matters reported out of committee
you got to be kidding in other words we
cannot agree that the house intended
that the right for the minority hearing
day can be fulfilled by scheduling a
hearing on a measure after the measures
voted out of the full committee I mean
it just doesn't make any sense so mr.
Collins would presume passage of these
articles of impeachment isn't the
minority hearing today now irrelevant I
believe it is and I believe that's the
concern that many of us have who
institutionally loved this place
okay mr. Raskin even if chairman Nadler
didn't believe the house rules required
him to schedule the minority hearing
prior to marking up the articles of
impeachment as a member of both
Judiciary Committee and Rules Committee
when you agree that would have been
better for the institution and the
American people not have been all this
disagreement partisan ranker just a
scheduled hearing it's just one day
Thank You mr. Kohl again I just learned
of it that the other day when mr.
Collins raised it and I looked at the
rule and the rule does say that the
chair of the committee is not required
to schedule the minority hearing as a
condition precedent to the continuing
course of legislative action and I
having been in the minority for my first
term here I feel your exasperation about
that that it might not happen before the
bill passes and if we want to make a
change to that rule I think that's
absolutely something that we should talk
about for future congresses well I
appreciate that I appreciate the
sentiment behind it because I know it's
sincere again I can go on and on on this
but we do believe mr. chairman it's a
violation of the Spirit why we
appreciate your letter very much which
is very respectful we tried to make ours
respectful when we made the request it
was to us the the facts are clear
chairman Nadler ignored a write the the
minority in committee being ignored by
the Democratic majority now and by doing
so it fundamentally alters the tools
available for the minority and all
future minorities so I do hope the Rules
Committee I'll correct this misguided
decision refrain from waiving all points
of order against the bill and very least
have the matter debated on the House
floor mr. Raskin after the adoption of
h.res 660 and before the Judiciary
Committee's first hearing pursuant to
that resolution ranking member Collins
wrote seven letters to chairman Nadler
on the subject of the committee's
consideration of impeachment on November
12th
II wrote chairman Nadler regarding the
manner in which the Intelligence
Committee conducted their investigation
on November 14th
he wrote chairman Nadler demanding that
the same transparency and fairness that
existed in Prior impeachment required
inquiries be prioritized in the current
inquiry on November 18th
he wrote chairman Nadler regarding the
credibility of a particular
witness and chairman shifts coordination
with certain witnesses to conceal basic
and relevant facts on November 21st
he wrote chairman Nadler asking that he
obtained all documents and information
from chairmanship pursuant to House
Resolution 661 November 30th the
persistent mr. Collins wrote chairman
Nadler asking for an expanded panel and
a balanced composition of academic
witnesses to apply on the subject matter
at issue during the December 4th hearing
on December 2nd he wrote chairman Nadler
asking for clarity on how he plans to
conduct the impeachment inquiry
referencing five previous letters he had
sent to questions that were never
answered and on December third he wrote
chairman Nadler reminding him of his
recent letters requesting that judiciary
committee provide the president due
process with the Intelligence Committee
and chairman Schiff did not
it's my understanding that chairman
Nadler never provided a response to any
of these letters your knowledge is
chairman Nadler generally not respond to
letters from ranking minority members no
and I will concede that mr. Collins
like Daffy were mentioned John Adams and
Thomas Jefferson is a prolific letter
writer I I don't know whether or not
they engage in conversation to follow up
on any of those but of course you know
we're all together on a daily basis
pretty much so well I just I can't speak
for the Chairman okay well I just want
to know for the record when we sent a
letter to my chairman he did respond and
we appreciate that very much to go
yeah I'm turning to you next oh yeah
it's irregular in my committee we don't
get a lot of answers and this was very
true we got one answer on our witness
list that was it the other one was a
discussion that I had when I asked for
another witness and it turned into an
interesting conversation all were you
asked him for three to two or asking for
ratios all I was asking for was another
witness and told me it was too late and
that he could add it you know it's just
it that felt like real I got I
appreciate the Chairman's under a lot of
pressure at time and calendar do kill
you
- and I recognized and that's true false
but you know this committee does in a
sense I was special responsibility to
make sure the other committees you know
operate according to our rules and
Mister common courtesy mr. Collins
articles impeachment are based on a
report written by the Chairman shift'
and transmitted Judiciary Committee
correct that's right did that
impeachment report rely on her hearsay
to support their insertion yes
what explanations chairmanship provide
when asked why here say rather than
firsthand testimony evidence was
incorrectly presented as evidence
well besides him his own discussion of
making up the phone calls start with
also he's not really provided one cuz he
didn't come testify my committee well
did you asked chairman Adler to invite
chairmanship to come testify I did just
to be clear you were asked to vote on
articles of impeachment against our
commander in chief based on a report
full of unsubstantiated allegations and
hearsay and you were not permitted to
ask the author to report any questions
that is correct all I got was a staff
member like to note for the record mr.
chairman the chairmanship refused to
discuss the report with the minority yet
he was more than willing to appear on
fox news sunday just two days ago and
it's unfortunately abundantly clear the
shift reports made it out for television
documents rather than the result of a
transparent thorough bipartisan
investigations were also worth noting
for the record I'll ask you this mr.
Collins was the president represents
that you know this is a really odd thing
for us because generally the Judiciary
Committee is the main committee of
impeachment that's historically been the
case that's clearly not the case here
the Committee on Intelligence is the
main committee yesterday have any
counsel there no it's someone somewhere
along the line we lost our right to be
the impeachment you know to work on it
because we got at the end to finish it
but we know there's a difference between
window dressing and substance I mean two
or three hearing at the end where you
don't even question the author of the
report on where you're not allowed to
question the author of the report on
which impeachment is based president
never had representation there in the
past we always had represent says you
were a traditionary the president was
there he could ask questions he could
but the main place where all these
things come out of president was
specifically excluded and you were not
in there and what's supposed to be the
main Committee on you were not allowed
to ask the author of the principal
report any question miss Coe you've just
presented in a short summation which
I've always admired by either the crux
of this whole problem by the time it got
to Judiciary Committee this was a done
deal the Train was on the front not him
on the track the train was past the
station they just had to run to catch up
to it it was already decided what they
wanted to do and so here it is and I've
heard this argument and you can dress
this up when dad rested anyway but I
think when we go to the intention
institutional integrity problem that we
have here when you get when you do
whatever you think of hrs 660 the only
place that truly provided the
opportunity for fairness for the
president and the administration was in
the Judiciary Committee because at that
point in time they would have been able
to the I asked the witnesses by the way
which they were turned down they were
you know that all these things that they
were but they were never opportunity
there's no way and I don't care how much
the majority pretties this up there's no
way you can call calling for Law School
professors to staff members and that's
the only hearings you have to provide
any opportunity for the president to
question and get anything out of them
but I have heard from my majority
colleagues which I was a former defense
attorney I think's pretty funny well if
he's innocent least tell them to come
prove it when is that ever part of what
we should be doing here really I don't
think any of my civil libertarians in
the Democratic aisle they ought to be
just laying awake at night saying how
can I be associated with this because no
matter what you think there's a way to
do this fairly and they could still get
the results because by the way they
still out numbers and they've been
trying to do this for three years
mr. raskins did you have any
conversations with chairmanship about
the contents of the report I'm certain I
have along the way yes really because
nobody on our side evidently you had any
conversation your knowledge did chairman
Adler have any conversations with
chairmen shift about the contents the
report oh I'm sorry when you say the
contents of the report you mean the
substance of what
in the report yeah well I think this is
none of our people have had that
opportunity I think well I think as a
committee we've been talking about the
substance of it for a long time now
but I I had not I mean well I was
talking about substance report we didn't
have any opportunity to question the
person who actually authored the report
oh I see what you mean okay and you're
formally or informally to my knowledge
well the again that the counsel for the
Intelligence Committee came over to
discuss all of the factual findings that
were in intelligence committees report
he's not the principal author of the
report he's the counsel for the
committee the Chairman's Princeton
principle okay
and and and by the way a fact witness as
well in many ways and so if I could
respond to this general line of attack
the House Resolution 661 umber of
significant procedural protections for
the president even on the house side and
as you know the role of the house is to
act as the grand jury and the prosecutor
in the actual trial takes place over in
the Senate but still we had very
significant procedural productions
including we invited the president and
his counsel to attend all hearings we
provided the president's counsel the
opportunity to cross-examine witnesses
and object to the admissible 'ti of
testimony and we provided the
president's counsel the opportunity to
make presentations of evidence before
the full Judiciary Committee including
the chance to call witnesses now the
president chose not to avail himself of
any of those opportunities so it's a
giddy reminds me of you know the
president blockading all these witnesses
and saying you don't have enough people
with direct first in the 2-night refer
first of all were those rights provided
only in Judiciary Committee because
you're not the principal committee of
impeachment here that's just the reality
but you're sort of the final stop so did
the president get those rights in the
judiciary can excuse me in the
intelligence committee I believe not I'd
have to go back and check but I can
assure you not well but let me let me
explain well you may accept this analogy
but here's the analogy that we proceeded
on because this is the first modern
impeachment where the fact finder
was the House of Representatives itself
instead of a special council or an
independent council when the special
council independent council did their
work in the Nixon in Clinton impeachment
so all of that was closed or depositions
because you don't want the witnesses to
be coordinating their testimony and so
on that's how prosecutorial
investigations take place the the House
Committee on Intelligence was our
fact-finding committee that's why they
performed closed-door depositions
because they wanted to avoid witnesses
coaching each other and coordinating
their testimony mr. Connolly I mean
we're driving down on the interesting
hole here because this is also and
ranking member the same committee that
said early on when were quote doing
impeachment that if the president saw
something he didn't want he could write
us a letter just like everybody else in
the world
this was actually said that he could
write a slur that would lead to how he
would be taken care of but let me hit a
couple of these things the White House
still has not received all the documents
supposed to have I mean we're still
we're here doing impeachment right now
and they still haven't received a letter
I still have not received all the
documents from the Intelligence
Committee that's in direct violation of
H 660 I don't know how we get around
that but we can pretend we can prank
pretty faces and say it doesn't happen
uh but also here's another thing the
staff member today sent mr. Goldman
would not testify or answer questions on
the methodology on how they actually did
their investigation and even in an
egregious violation in their own report
where they named members of Congress and
their phone records he would not
actually say who ordered that was it
chairmanship for him now I've always
defaulted as I think you would mr. Cole
to the member with the pen which would
be mr. Shipp but mr. Goldman actually
sat there and said we would not discuss
the methodology of their investigation
this has got to be just the most amazing
thought when you come to an impeachment
when you're trying to give due process
to the President of the United States
and these are all ignored and we can
pretty it up any way we want to but it's
just not buying this is not right and
look you will impeach him you have the
votes but at the end of the day is it
worth the integrity of the house I don't
think so
during the staff presentation the
evidence ranking member Collins asked
how the investigation he just made this
point was conducted resulted in the
shift report never got an answer mr.
Raskin the House Intelligence Committee
Democrats early
phone records including four phone calls
by intelligence committee ranking member
knitters how did the committee Democrats
get those phone records I'm gonna have
to ask the staff council to pass me a
note on that I will say but the staff
council didn't answer that is that
correct mr. Koz
no you wouldn't ask the questions so
telling us to go ask somebody who can
answer the question well I understand
that we forcefully represented that
there that no member of the House of
Representatives and no member of the
press was targeted with any
investigative resources oh that's mr.
mr. Coe really I mean I respect Minister
asking but I'm not even sure he got that
statement out without stumbling over
everything you cannot say that you take
I mean this is we need to talk about
metadata talking about numbers at some
point somebody with the ranking members
phone number had to go down through
there and look for the ranking members
phone number they had to go down and
look for mr. Solomon's phone number this
is what they don't want to deal with
this is how bad it is screwed up and I
know they wanted call sober process I
know they want to gloss over how they
did their investigation because their
time in the calendar are terrible
masters I've repeated it over and over
but this is what we're talking about and
they wouldn't even talk about so to say
that there's you know that nobody was
doing this intentionally it's just not
being factually accurate it doesn't
happen on its own
I asked both of you this question who
specifically match the number own
numbers of ranking member newness and
what method did they use but I have no
idea I just wonder if I could save mr. :
sponsor the whole line of questions the
President of the United States was given
the opportunity to call any witnesses he
want any of the 17 witnesses who
appeared before the House Intelligence
Committee and oversight and the Foreign
Affairs could have been called by the
president he would have had the
opportunity to cross-examine any of them
but of course he didn't want to because
all of them essentially told different
pieces of the exact same story which is
the president it's executed this
shakedown of President Solinsky to come
and get involved in our campaign at the
expense of former vice president Barlow
doesn't hold water when you look at her
again I can't say this enough he goes
back to our calendar and a clock how is
it possible when I talked to the
chairman himself sending letters asking
you know when we were gonna get
witnesses when he didn't even build the
witness day in for ourselves
he didn't even build in the calendar a
time to accept one of our witnesses much
less the White House witnesses so don't
tell me that you could have accepted
heat or sent witnesses and we had
accepted it was never on the calendar
man is because these numbers didn't
particularly need who specifically
ordered the inclusion of phone these
phone records and the shift report mr.
ranking member I'm afraid I can't answer
these questions I just don't know let's
see well and Dolly was the Intelligence
Committee carrying out what seemed to be
a political vendetta against another
member of Congress either of you think
it's proper to add the names of
individuals swept up in call logs so
we're not the targeted criminal
investigation of their names no it is
nothing but a political drama and I
bought that out they could have done it
several different ways they could have
said number one it could have been in
person one they could have done it any
other way but they chose to actually use
the names this was a political hit job
give you do you think it was appropriate
for those numbers and names have been
released again I the targets of the
investigations they were just swept up
you know yeah I I was not involved in
that part of it and so forgive me
against me no I ever again I understand
the gentleman yield for a minute we did
have testimony on this no I'm not gonna
yield my time okay I mean there was time
shortly yeah no Scala tests one it was
I'm not gonna tell you okay
how many times mr. Collins's shift
report or hearsay statements use this
evidence hundreds well actually only 54
it may seem when you take off one person
talking off another person off another
person it goes how many times in the
ship reporter news reports the only
evidence supporting factual assertions
I'm sorry to Preet the question house
come on how many times in the shift
reporter news reports the only evidence
supporting factual assertions it would
have been the main factual assertion was
mr. Soglin born about 16 different times
mr. Atkins my understanding
Schiff did not transmit the evidence
collected during his committees
investigation to the Judiciary Committee
until Friday December 6th as does that
comport with your memory that that is
correct okay so just sherry committee
majority did it have access to any
evidence beyond the actual report from
the Intelligence Committee until the
weekend before the Judiciary Committee
actually considered articles of
impeachment well I don't remember
exactly when all of the deposition
statements were released publicly I
think some of them had been released
publicly before at that time would we go
back and check the exact chronology sure
yeah though certain members the Detroit
committee who are also members of other
intimately understand your it's my
understanding that chairmanship did not
transmit all the material collected by
the Intelligence Committee to the
Judiciary Committee is that the case
it's still true to this day so would you
not agree and not asked us to both of
you the House Judiciary Committee should
have had the time and opportunity to
review all that material collected by
the Intelligence Committee did you both
have that time and opportunity we did
notice a direct violation of house rule
6 Resolution 661 can tell you is the the
vast amount of what we ended up getting
was what was being produced released
publicly along the way I know the
Intelligence Committee made the
commitment to release those depositions
those deposition statements publicly and
I and so I've considered it a very fair
and transparent process I didn't I don't
think I got to see a single thing
through the Judiciary Committee that I
was not just seeing come out and being
released by the Intelligence Committee
in any event all of it is in the final
report it's there for all of America to
see and I don't want us to lose sight of
the big picture we really don't know if
it's all there we don't have a report
from if you haven't seen them yourself
no we do not know that that's a
statement that is assuming something you
know facts not in evidence that that we
don't know what we you know this is the
old classic case of evidence being given
from
Skeeter - you know in a trial we don't
know what we're not singing we do know
what we know one a few things we know
have not been transferred but we'd also
have heard of other things that's not
been transferred and it's not can't be
under report if it's not been
transferred because then we can at least
say it was in the report let me move on
to the articles themselves because in my
view we've established the Intelligence
Committee process was substantially
flawed and procedurally defective that's
my view I underlined Judiciary Committee
failed to create an evidentiary record
sufficient to justify moving forward on
articles if you basically relied on the
Intelligence Committee again where the
president was unrepresented that
violated rules of the house in my view
and the entire circus has been
politically motivated from the very
beginning on the obstruction of Congress
charge it's uncommon for the executive
is it uncommon for the NISS of both of
you uncommon for the executive branch to
push back against requests for
information from Congress well no it is
not uncommon for the executive branch to
push back on the production of this with
that document or the timing of a
particular visit what was absolutely
breathtaking in its unprecedented and
radical nature was this president's
determination to shut down all discovery
they did not produce a single document
to us mr. call that was subpoenaed in
this process and the president
essentially ordered everyone in the
executive branch not to cooperate with
us yes excuse me I don't know I think
that's a dramatic escalation in kind and
in degree over anything that's ever been
seen before and that includes Richard
Nixon who I think tried to tried to
block seven or eight particular requests
like the Watergate tapes and that in
itself became part of the case against
him for abuse of power but you know
President Trump makes Richard Nixon look
like a little leaguer when it comes to
obstruction mr. Kile the same thing do
you think it's unusual for an
administration to push back against
congressional subpoenas and no it's
common if it's pretty
you believe it's a high crime or
misdemeanor to assert privileges in
response to congressional requests for
subpoenas not it is and again I won't go
back and just give a little bit of
history since we've had history lessons
here from it's rather even our own
committee this year what's been really
interesting is is is there's been a
total you know just walk toward
impeachment the whole time but what was
interesting in our committee is we would
send subpoenas or we would you know
again we sent out letters and stuff and
we never followed up home but also one
of the interesting things about our
committee was as we never engaged for
the most part with the agencies for
documents but what I thought was really
interesting was mr. Schiff in the
Intelligence Committee while we were
still struggling during Moeller and some
other times mr. Schiff actually
negotiated with the Department of
Justice and actually got documents
released that our committee couldn't the
House Foreign Affairs Committee eliot
engel who is one of the quadrants but
one of the more effective and my person
from across the aisle had engaged all
year with an administration on ways to
get documents it's a matter of how you
go about it and to say that this is just
unheard of it's just not right well and
then again I'd ask this to both you know
I think this gets to the point you're
making there's a normal accommodations
process for resolving interbranch
disputes between the house and the
executive branch is that not correct yes
okay and that process really hasn't
occurred here I think mr. Collins that's
what you tell them that presumably it
doesn't fit neatly into the the you know
speakers impeachment and Christmas
timeline to borrow your your way of
looking at it I mean we've not gone to
court know how these things we're not
really engaged
this is a normal give-and-take we're
actually both sides tend to avoid quote
you know an exchange where they might go
to court and lose something but all
that's been set aside we haven't had any
process like that heavily no miss Cole I
even point out something that I disagree
with mr. McGann well I mean there's been
a court case in which we've lost in
which mr. McGann and is still being
appealed but it does show you the
process or you just don't work as fast
as they want to work and I think that's
where we have to go back to in this
whole process so no in fact even the one
that they had that was actually one of
the members administration contested
they just withdrew their subpoena and
we've driven from the from the lawsuit
because they just
I'll deal with it I know mr. Raskin
would have a different view and if he
wants to respond that would have to do
specifically mr. Collins there any
actual evidence that the paws on the
crane Ian's assistance was for the
president's improper personal political
benefit or could he have had other
objectives that's directed to you mr.
Collins
I'm sorry appalled us and it's all right
I'm throwing a lot of questions at you
is there any actual evidence that the
paws on the Ukranian assistance was for
the president's improper personal
political benefit or might he have had
other reasons for withholding aid and
plenty of other reasons and I think the
part of it is the law itself which says
that you know even though the certified
it was the president's call to make sure
that there was no corruption in where I
eat is given there was other countries
during that time was aid was held I
think from an appropriator standpoint
mr. Cole you'll also understand this aid
was not even scheduled to go out it had
to be done by September 30 it actually
went out early if you look at it from
that time frame so there were other
reasons there was a recent poll just to
show you and again we talked about this
a little bit from our side the
corruption in the Ukraine was so
prevalent six recent poll says 68
percent of normal everyday Ukrainians
had said that they had bribe a public
official in the past year there was
reasons for this to be discussed and
reasons to go at it but I also want to
point out one last thing on this other
issue fast and furious the infamous
issue with the Obama administration it
was seven months from first subpoena to
first documents seven months so that
this is an essential point that you
raise right now and I think that there
is not any credible evidence from any of
the witnesses or anything in the record
to suggest that the president was
actually trying to ferret out corruption
as opposed to impose a corrupt scheme on
the president of Ukraine let's start
with this in 2017 and 2018 the president
could have raised corruption in
withholding military and security
assistance to Ukraine and never did
then in 2019 he did what changed well
Joe Biden was running for president and
the presidential campaign was much on
his mind the president
removed ambassador Jovanovic and we
learned today from from mr. Giuliani
that he was involved with the campaign
by Parnassus and Froome into smear
ambassador Jovanovic to say there was
something wrong with her in fact when
she was according to all the testimony
we had and all the public information we
have she was one of the leading
anti-corruption ambassadors that the
United States has on earth and they
sabotaged her they undercut her they
subjected her to an unprecedent smear
campaign that led several of the other
witnesses to protest that the State
Department was not standing by its own
ambassador and they got rid of her as
mr. Giuliani
said in today's paper because she was
getting in the way of the investigations
they wanted and what investigations were
those those into Biden those into the
2016 conspiracy did so that's pretty
clear it had nothing to do with
corruption moreover if you go to the
July 25th telephone call president Trump
never raised the word corruption once
but he did talk about Joe Biden three
times so we didn't hear corruption
corruption corruption we heard Biden
Biden Biden that was the favor that we
were looking for right he wanted the
president of Ukraine to come over and
say he was investigating the Biden's
look that's a unrefuted and
uncontradicted in the record I don't we
should I don't think we should be trying
to pull the wool over America's eyes
about this let's not play make-believe
if we want to say it's okay for the
President to do this stuff let's just go
ahead and say it but let's not claim
that he was involved in some kind of
anti-corruption crusade at the time I
think America knows that we can't take
that seriously this president cut
anti-corruption funding to Ukraine by
50% the chairman of his campaign Paul
Manafort was on the take he was on the
dole for millions of dollars to a former
corrupt president in Ukraine President
zalenski who was getting shaken down was
the reformer he was the product of the
revolution of dignity in 2014 which
tried to bring some democracy and tried
to bring some fairness and
anti-corruption efforts to Ukraine
Giuliani and his gang that can't shoot
straight
they went over there because they wanted
to take advantage of this situation and
go back to the corrupt forces in Ukraine
so this
president had one thing in mind his own
reelection and how president Solinsky
could help him and you can see that if
you look at the phone conversation than
ambassador Sunland had with the
president the day after July 25th on
July 26 he had this phone conversation
that was partially overheard by David
Holmes in the State Department and he
hears him tell the president that
zalenski will do whatever you want he's
gonna do the investigations he loves
your ass and so on and then he gets off
the phone and then he tells him what
that what the president is interested in
is the big stuff relating to the
president's own political ambitions like
the Biden's he's not interested in the
war with Russia and I would say
obviously he's not interested in
corruption he was interested in the
Biden's and that was it now either we
think that's an appropriate and proper
thing for the president night states to
be doing where we think it's wrong well
the deal of us believe it rises to the
level I want to want to give us a chance
to respond before I do
president zalenski any Ukrainian
official ever tell you they felt shaken
down well there's lots of evidence in
the round what I asked I said if you got
any okay and they had their any
statement on the record I don't think so
no there's statements on the record the
record ours wasn't we wasn't pressure we
wasn't part of the anything I wouldn't
be a part of that those are the
statements from mr. szalinski
well yo don't let at this point are
contemporaneous emails where and
somebody will pass me the exact language
but essentially we're mr. Dermott who is
the the top right-hand man to the
president of Ukraine says that the
President does not want to be treated as
a political pawn in domestic American
politics for several weeks they were
doing everything in their power to try
to get out from underneath the
straightjacket this scheme that was
coming there was bearing down on them
from every different direction mr. Koz
wow that's a story right there this is
my I am maybe the
we're having to expand the story to fit
our narrative here and because you know
if you don't let's don't play might
believe there's nothing if they had
something in the phone call it we've
been in the articles of impeachment they
don't because at the end of the day
there's no direct evidence of what
they're trying to spin here and that was
that there was a pressuring or a quid
pro quo or however you want to put it -
mr. szalinski the problem here is is it
marks and II testified under oath there
was a wholesale investigation going into
foreign aid this year so you can go back
and quote 2017-2018 all you want but
this year because of the problems he
testified that there's a wholesale
investigation on the foreign aid
everywhere Trump well but if you know
the president Trump actually raised this
mr. poroshenko in 2017 and that was
testified to by mr. Volker and the
former ambassador so when you look at
this there's no direct evidence of what
was said here and to try and then come
back and put this into a different
perspective and again going back to mr.
Yarmuth who mr. garvik said there was no
connection between ever discussed
between the the aid and a investigation
and also if they were trying to get out
from under it so hard i guess if we're
looking at it because they never did
anything to get the aid they never did
anything to get the a that they were
that scared something was wrong I'll try
to bring this to inclusion because I and
I know there'll be a difference of
opinion here so you've both certainly
both can respond contrary to my claims
or to my friends claims cross the out
mr. Collins you think the Democratic
majority effectively denied the
administration a meaningful opportunity
to participate in this proceeding that
in effectively did okay on october 30 if
the rules committee held our original
jurisdiction markup on hrs 660 there
were many serious concerns from our side
the diocese about the damage this
unprecedented process to have the
institution Republican members of the
committee were repeatedly assured that
quote the president has been afforded
all kinds of rights before the Judiciary
Committee before that assertion again
today and that this would be an open and
transparent process despite the fact
that we received the text of the
resolution a mere 24 hours earlier did
not have a single
amendment made in order mr. Collins was
the administration provided the
opportunity to participate in the
Intelligence Committee proceeding
because of my mind no basically
supplanted the judiciary is to principle
committee of impeachment they were they
definitely want an in judiciary and you
could think it was put into the record
that they should have been but the
problem is is the actual way it played
out in the scheduling in Judiciary
Committee made it nowhere possible that
they could even if all of a sudden they
wanted it there was no time in the
calendar for it
now it's not just end with this I mean
well let my friend respond if you need
wanted to say thank you you're very kind
mr. Kaul the when lieutenant colonel VIN
Minh testified he said that this request
for a favor was not in any sense a
friendly request it was a demand in the
context of the hundreds of millions of
dollars that were being held up the
request for the White House meeting in
so on for weeks the Ukrainians pushed
back on the demand of the president his
agents and advised US officials they did
not want to be quote an instrument in
Washington domestic re-election politics
you recall the testimony of dr. Fiona
Hill who said that this was a domestic
political errand that the president's
team was on in order to extract this
commitment from President Solinsky to
come and give this interview and in fact
they had publicly announced there they
were gonna publicly announced
investigations in an interview that
President zalenski
had scheduled on CNN but then Ukraine
cancelled the interview a few days after
the president's scheme was publicly
exposed in the military aid got released
in other words when the whole scheme
blew up then President Solinsky felt
that he could be free from this
obligation to come forward and say he
was investigating with all due respect
President was telling the United States
senators in August the aide was probably
going to be released long before you
know there was any notion about a
whistleblower or anything else senator
Johnson from Wisconsin has testified to
that
fact well and again with all due respect
I mean the last administration for four
years didn't provide any military
assistance to Ukraine the idea that 55
days was somehow life and death in this
situation particularly during a period
of transition from one government to
another you know it's just pretty thin
gruel to impeach a president of the
United States on with chairman McCaul
due respect to my friends here who I
admire both and who I think have been
very helpful in their testimony and as
always straight and forthright my view
chairman shift ought to be the person
answering questions in front of the
Rules Committee
it's his report I don't blame the
president for passing on the opportunity
not skill before the judiciary for what
was clearly going to be profund tree and
provide a sort of window dressing of
legitimacy to this process so the claim
that he was given meaningful or
consistent opportunities treated
anywhere like previous administration I
just don't think holds up when you're
denied an opportunity to participate
with the principal actions at and then
given a last minute thing and so again I
just I'm gonna yield back my time mr.
Chairman I want to thank both of our
distinguished members former and current
of the Rules Committee for coming up
here and and providing us their insight
and our testimony it's it's great to
work with both of you and I appreciate
your service to your districts and to
the Congress and to the country you back
so I want to thank the gentleman for his
questioning I said I'd be liberal with
the time you knew you were you're gonna
make me into a conservative by the
but let me let me just do a couple of
things here one is I want to ask
unanimous consent to without objection
to insert of the record in October 23rd
New York Times article entitled Ukraine
Ukraine knew of aid freeze by early
August undermining Trump defense I also
want to make a couple of comments about
the minority de witness issue I did send
a letter to my colleagues on the Rules
Committee we made it part of the record
mr. Nadler is confirmed that he would
work with a minority to schedule of
their hearing day on constitutional
grounds of impeachment not with staying
the fact he already had a minority
witness and we we did a lot of history
we did looked at the history of this
whole of this whole rule and basically
was designed to ensure that the minority
was not shut out of witnesses that there
were not complete shut of hearings as
had been as had occurred in the past and
the minority did get a witness I tried
not to watch the judiciary proceedings
as much as I could but I did see him he
was there but I would just say that you
know that this sight this notion that
somehow that the minority has this super
power ability to be able to not only
name the witnesses but set the day and
to be able to slow down progress on any
bill if that were the case having been
in the minority for 8 years we would
have used it to stop most of the agenda
that my Republican friends have put
forward so I put that I would again just
I will make that letter available to
anybody who's interested mr. McGovern
yes chairman I do have a quote I was you
made a statement and I'm not sure if you
were how you were wording into feels a
paraphrase or I was never promised by
mr. Nadler that he would work with us on
minority hearing day from now to
infinity I mean he just he just
basically said no we're not having it
well maybe not my understand is that he
said that in committee maybe I'm wrong
but I we go far we had a real issue of
consultation we will look that up and
and by the time we get back we will get
you get that you that answer but let me
let me again remind everybody here why
we're here today because I get kind of
get caught up into the weeds in to talk
about process and let me let me I just
was handed it now there instead of so
I'm willing to work with the minority to
schedule the hearing up I'll pass it on
to the to the gentleman if we have
consultation issues in our committee and
sending that and not talking about and
taking all of our witnesses out is not
true and to impugn it into letters fine
but it's still not true so I you know I
will ask that to be part of the record
as well look let me let me just remind
everybody why we're here as I said over
and over again the president abused his
power of office for his own personal
gain and obstructed a congressional
investigation to look into that conduct
and we all know how he did it he try to
shake down the government of Ukraine to
basically get dirt on his political
opponent to help him in the upcoming
twenty twenty election and he engaged in
a systemic pattern of denying any
documents of any cooperation with
Congress that is obstruction of Congress
and mr. Collins you you kept on saying
something that I actually agree with you
talk about other o'clock and the
calendar is important you know from my
vantage point and from the way I looked
at what has happened here it is
important because I believe as mr.
Raskin stated at the beginning of his
testimony that there is a crime in
progress may we have an election coming
up in less than a year and the president
is openly trying to encourage foreign
interference in that election I mean
that is a big deal that should shock
everybody not only in this committee in
this chamber all throughout this country
it is just wrong it is so wrong and so
we will continue this hearing where but
we just we just had votes and we will
recess and come back at the beginning of
the last vote where we will then turn to
mr. Hastings the Rules Committee stands
in recess
[Music]
[Music]
who owns the image of a national hero a
picture of the revolutionary leader
Emiliano Zapata by the artist
vivillon Titus has sparked great
controversy here in Mexico
social media and has even led to violent
clashes between farmers collectives who
believe that the image of the
revolutionary hero is being tarnished
and by LGBT activists who defend the
picture lucha por una casa
gratis ariados de trabajar dope or Dante
GoPro Puente de nuestra for Dignidad
Foreman the us at a baby
whatever that convention is importa por
la casilla
the controversy has even reached mexican
president after this manner lopez
obrador
said that he does not tolerate these
acts of violence so far the museum has
agreed
statement by the sifaka family next to
this portrait are saying that they
disagree with this suspection
who does the image of Emiliano Zapata
belong to the pictures of him show him
in many different forms they evoke many
different feelings many of them of anger
towards the status quo but this
particular depiction shows Zapata
that many in the LGBT community can
identify with farmers collectives have
called for more protests the exhibit
will take place for a couple of months
so we will see what transpires in the
next few weeks
[Music]
something about the song
[Music]
[Music]
the oil palm plantations are farmed
sustainably there is no other
agricultural crop in this world which
can produce as much with so little and
this on a larger scale has a huge
environmental impact in a positive way
in terms of requiring less land to feed
a world population which is going to
reach 10 billion people in another 30
years
[Music]
[Music]